good afternoon ladies and gentlemen or
at least this afternoon in Houston Texas
um I'm pleased to um be here today to
talk to you about lowering blood culture
contamination rates using an
evidence-based medicine approach and one
of the things that I noticed at um the
recent American Society for microbiology
meeting um in Boston about less than a
week ago is um that everything now seems
to be outcome studies or evidence-based
medicine and probably rightly so so what
we're going to look at actually here is
a systematic review approach that was
developed by the Centers for Disease
Control and prevention in
collaboration with the American Society
for
microbiology and basically um we've used
this now not only on this um particular
um systematic review that you're we're
going to talk about today but um in
several that the American Society for
microbiology is taking the lead on in
collaboration with the Centers for
Disease Control which brings me to an
introduction for myself um I'm Alice
weissfeld and I'm the laboratory
director microbiology specialist
Incorporated and I'm talking to you
today as the chair of the
asm's evidence-based medicine committee
um which is part of the ASM professional
practice committee and I have a history
um somewhat of a history in um writing
guidelines because um in the late 70s um
I was on the editorial board of asm's
cumitech we had a lot different approach
to how we wrote guidelines in those days
because what we used to do was actually
appoint people and say okay you're an
expert you're an expert you're an expert
and then write the guidelines and I've
since realized once seeing the CDC
actual um how the actual guidelines are
written in this systematic way um how
silly that seems in retrospect but I
guess in in those days it was the best
that we
had so I thought that I would start out
um by just giving you um some
information about the CDC um
evidence-based medicine approach and
then um go into how it has applied in
this issue of blood culture
contamination the CDC method is also
known as the A6 cycle and you can see
why there are six A's because each of
the the different steps um starts with
an A so in in looking at a quality gap
or a policy problem the first thing we
do is we ask a question and the question
in this particular case is going to
involve um why how can we reduce the um
blood culture contamination that we
usually
see um the next a the second a A2 is to
acquire information I'm going to show
you how we do that but we do that with
the help of a Professional Medical
librarian the third step
A3 is to appraise the evidence and this
is done by a very torturous but very
transparent method in which we use
everybody uses the same form to actually
assess papers and two people have to
become um experts on each of the papers
that they're assigned if they don't
agree in their assessment it's sent to a
third the next step is A4 analyze and
what the people are doing um in this
step is basically sending data that has
been rated either good or fair to a meta
statistician who does a metaanalysis and
creates Forest plots which you'll see
later that actually show you um whether
the whether what you're looking at um as
a method to improve um patient outcomes
is actually better worse or no different
than the method that you have looked at
before um A5 is an apply step A6 is an
assess step um we're not going to talk
about those today we're just going to
get to the analyze step um but the CDC
um has issued um like Cooperative
agreements and ASM was awarded one in
which um we're actually seeing um if we
have a clear um picture of what the best
way to do things are are laboratorians
actually doing that and if they're not
why aren't they and those are the apply
and assess um techniques which will not
be the subject of today's
talk okay so again um the first thing
that you look for and look at a
laboratory medicine best practices um
systematic review question is um what is
the problem or what is um what are you
looking at and the answer here for the
question is what practices are effective
for reducing blood culture
contamination and you might have also
heard um outcome studies called Pico
studies and you can see that I've
highlighted the p i c and O and the p in
Pico stands for the population so in
this case um we could have been doing
studies on how many children um have had
blood cultures collected and how many
are contaminated but in this particular
one our question is of all patients who
have had blood cultures collected at our
institution how many of them actually um
have a better outcome because of changes
that were made for intervention versus
what the comparator or the comparison is
we studied um Vena puncture versus IV
catheter draw um and that's from an
indwelling catheter that people have um
placed in some cases photomy teams
versus nonfamous staff collections um
and uh this would be um for example um
having n nursing or some other people
other than a team of FLOTUS collect
house staff that kind of thing and then
um the third thing was to look at do
prepackage prep kits that have the beta
dine and um the alcohol and the syringe
and everything included make any
difference or result in a better outcome
than if you have just the individual
components in a tray so that you have no
actual prep hit but the the components
individually and then our outcome in
this particular study is a reduced blood
culture contamination
rate okay the first thing that you do
after defining your question and looking
at the Pico information is to actually
prepare an analytical framework and if
you read all of the different um
systematic reviews that have been done
by the CDC method um you're going to see
this same analytical framework um in
every one of these and actually um the
seminal article for those of you who may
know Rob Christensen who is a former
president of AAC the chemistry
Association um he wrote the seminal
article with CDC about how you do an A6
systematic
review so the first thing is to address
what is the quality problem which is
essentially restating what we saw in the
last slide and here the quality problem
is going to look at um contamination of
blood cultures um produces false
positive test results um there is not
really a bloodstream infection and what
we're worri about as far as patient
outcomes is this can lead to adverse
patient outcomes be and wasted Health
Care Resources because those um patients
are often put on antimicrobials that
they don't need um and have increased
length of stay and other issues so um
that is our quality problem um the
preventability and Improvement part of
it is can we lower our blood culture
contamination rate and all microbiology
Labs monitor their blood culture
contamination rate as one of the things
that you do for quality assurance and
you can see here that in the literature
the range of contamination that people
report is as low as
0.6% and as high as
12.5% and in this particular guid line
they were looking for a target of 3%
because the American Society for
microbiology and The Clinical Laboratory
standards Institute have said that
3% is a good place to be and anything
above that you need to have an
intervention to try to lower your rate
um anything below that um is Kudos um
for your
institution now the next part of the
analytical framework is looking at what
are the interventions and practices
we've already talked about that again in
the C part of the Pico and that is we're
going to look at Vena puncture whether
it is improved overusing IV C ceter
collection we're going to look at
whether a photomy team of dedicated
staff is better than just using other
either house staff or nursing Personnel
or other people who are trained to draw
blood and we're going to look at whether
prepackaged prep kits are better than
just using individual
components um and we like to look at in
within this some of the harms and the
harms could be if you're if you're like
contaminating the blood um a needl stick
inj injury risk or um a patient
collection site infection when they
didn't need to you know like have it
because they usually redrawn once they
come up with a positive and they may not
have had to have that second
collection um we look at
intermediate outcomes and then over to
the right um healthc care um outcomes
and so so an intermediate house um
outcome is to look at blood culture
contamination rates um additional
testing as we just discussed um which
may not be necessary any followup
associated with a re-evaluation because
a physician comes back the patient has
no fever no other signs of sepsis um but
they draw them again and then any cost
associated with either an unnecessary
draw or an unnecessary um
antimicrobial um
therapy um and then for the health care
outcomes um there are obviously going to
be Diagnostic and treatment delays
because there's always the question of
whether um during that draw you contam
got a contaminated draw and you missed
um because of low numbers the actual
organism causing
sepsis um Diagnostic and treatment
errors that occur because of that
unnecessary and increased hospital stays
um unnecessary antibiotic use um
Hospital acquired infection um and cost
associated with the above in essence um
the effects of morbidity or mortality
changes because of the fact that the
blood culture was not collected
properly in order to do one of these A6
reviews um it's very organized in that
the review coordinator has the the
primary responsibility for actually
conducting the
review and the review coordinator is
usually picked um because they um are
familiar with um good scientific method
um they have a relationship or are
willing to develop a relationship with a
li medical
librarian um and they're willing to um
lead what is in some cases um a very
intense discussion um in order to get to
um what are the best practices so the
review coordinator um appoints a review
team um this includes um because we work
with the CDC um a CDC lays on an ASM
lays on um a lead technical person um
and then the review coordinated
themselves um there is also an expert
panel um who have the science I ific and
Technical um Authority from the
membership to make decisions on behalf
of the membership and these people
either um are selected from experts um
in the field or from people who have
volunteered to do this the second thing
the review coordinator does is actually
um devise a literature search strategy
with the the medical librarian so in
looking at the analytical framework work
that we just saw one of the things that
happens is that you develop keyword and
for those of you who have written
manuscripts um for years we actually
have put down keywords that the authors
think will help to identify those
particular papers when somebody is
searching so for example um this could
be photomy teams can be a search word or
whatever um and this is very important
because you want to make sure that
you've gotten all of the
literature um then um the review
coordinator gets the information from
the medical librarian reviews abstracts
um and as what we call assembles
pertinent
literature and assesses is this um
something that you know we have enough
information for um and are these
pertinent to the questions that we're
asking again in this case Vena punct
versus um a line draw um whether we um
should use prepackaged kits versus just
individual components
Etc um the review coordinator will
assign two independent reviewers from
this expert panel for each reference
that they feel is um applicable to the
subject matter um these people assist
with the data
abstractions um and then when the data
extractions are sent back the review
coordinator organizes and codes the
literature um following the um CDC A6
method the review coord coordinator also
compiles the evidence summaries um if
you've looked at these types of papers
um they're a body of evidence tables for
each question and those are prepared by
the review coordinator in concert with
the bio statis
um they coordinate the evaluation of
unpublished data in the review process
and one of the first ones of these that
the American Society for microbiology
did by themselves was on bloodstream
infections and whether some of the rapid
PCR assays resulted in better patient
outcomes um because of the fact that
rapid testing was performed um albeit
that the rapid testing um may have added
cost to the actual Laboratory
test um in the information that was
available at the time that ASM did this
um we were not able to make a
recommendation either for or against
whether that was important but what we
are doing is we're actually um in that
paper um giving people a way to be able
to upload data that can also be
abstracted and reviewed um in the new
review process when we look at this
again in about a year um and a lot of
people have data but they haven't been
able to publish it or it's been rejected
or for whatever reason it's not in the
published literature so one of the
things I really like about the CDC
method is that we can look at
unpublished data and either people can
say I want my data to go into the mix
and don't say who I am or they can say
you know like please let people know
that this hospital um contributed the
information um that has been used in
this and this literature you might hear
if you're interested in this is now
known as the gray literature because
it's out there people know from their
own QA studies what it is but it just
hasn't been
published um finally the review
coordinator evaluates the evidence
summaries and evidence tables and
produces Direct
recommendations um and then um the CDC
has an lmdp workg group um which are
composed of various
laboratorians um who actually take a
look at this um question the results and
if everything is good um the data is
then published with those
recommendations okay so let's look at
specifically what happened in the blood
culture contamination
search um we look at three databases
usually PubMed which um many of you are
familiar with I'm sure um and then mbase
and stel and these in looking at this we
look at English language articles from
1995 to 2012 with regard to human
subjects um and the medical librarian is
a key in you know like working with the
review coordinator in finding those
articles
there's also hand searching of
bibliographies from relevant information
sources um one of the things that we
discovered in one of our guidelines that
we're working on on urinate Track
Transport and collection was that um
some papers that we were reading had
references that were not in our
bibliography and we should be able to
say at the end of the day that we've
captured everything that's relevant to
the information source so in order to do
that um during this period we look very
carefully at the literature to see if
there are any things that have not been
um found by the librarian for whatever
reason um this time is also when we
solicit any um published quality
improvement studies um so that we can
add these in and for the blood culture
contamination um there have been um
three or four institutions
that have since submitted blood culture
contamination data from their own
institutions okay for the screening
criteria for um initial appraisal of
evidence the first thing that you want
to do is exclude things that obviously
are not applicable um in some cases you
get over 2,000 articles and even with a
large number of people on the expert
panel it's a daun task to try to look at
2,000 articles so you first as as I said
on a on another slide go through and the
review coordinator is looking at is this
a situation where um this is even
applicable and the way you do that is um
is in this paper a there there a
practice that's relevant to the topic
question that's being assessed so if
you're looking at um you know whether um
blood should be drawn um using a photomy
team or not then you know like Bas and
you know like they're they're talking
about in the paper um antimicrobial
therapy um at the time of you know blood
culture positivity obviously that's not
going to be a paper that you're going to
review because it's not in the practice
that you're looking
at um also um the practice U may not
have been sufficiently disc described in
the paper that you're looking at or the
description is inconsistent with the
evidence review practice definition that
we developed in the framework so this is
this is pretty rigid so that we can
actually be sure that we're looking at
the things that we want to know that we
decided we wanted to know before
everything started and then we obviously
don't use anything that is either
commentary or opinion letters to the
editor unless they contain additional
information that's considered
important inclusion criteria is just the
opposite if um something is to be
included because it's talking about
something that we want to um look at
then we do the full text and abstraction
by two me members of the expert panel
and basically um what you do in this
case is uh you make sure that there's at
least one aspect of the topic IC
addressed in that manuscript that you're
reviewing that it's in use and available
for adoption that it's reproducible in
other comparable settings so if one
person tells you that they use a photomy
team and everybody else says that they
don't in the paper um it's not
necessarily going to be helpful for
photomy teams but um this is part of
what's addressed as you look for um the
information
um you need to make sure that you're
addressing a defined population of
patients and that it has um potential
impact on the outcome related to one of
the following Health Care Quality aims
um and the government has spent a lot of
money recently looking at improving the
delivery um of Health Care by looking at
these aims so these are things that you
um potentially going to hear about when
you're talking to um your colleagues in
healthcare
and those are Effectiveness efficiency
patient centeredness which is at the
heart of everything that we're trying to
do in the laboratory safety timeliness
and Equity so you want to you want to
make sure that um what you're doing is
um addressing some of these issues as
well so here's the flow diagram and
again this is included in um all system
systematic reviews um for the blood
culture contamination and you can see
how this is Whitted down so there are
four over 450 records that were
identified from various
databases um of these databases um there
always duplicates that you get because
the um topic is pulled from different
keywords so
348 were excluded um and then if you
look up on the top um 50 additional
records were identified that were not
identified during the actual um review
by the librarian two that were
unpublished um and 13 from hand
searches um so basically 108 records
finally were screened for practice
Effectiveness um 87 were excluded um
because inclusion criteria were not met
they were left with 21 full Tech studies
um to actually look at for the expert
panel four were excluded um in the end
because of study quality criteria not
being met and so um if you look at the
actual systematic review the manuscript
um out of
456 studies 15 more um that were found
um by looking for additional records
only 17 studies were included in the
analysis so there's a lot of culling out
that happens um to get down to just the
questions and it turns out that of those
17 studies um third nine were on Veno
puncture versus
catheterization um using a cath a
catheter to um actually draw the blood
um five were on photomy teams um and
whether they were better and four were
on prepack packaged prep kits so there
aren't a terribly High number of actual
papers that you're left with and one of
the things that has held up is that the
CDC says that if there are at least
three that actually work um you can
actually make some kind of decision as
long as the statistician says that it
meets the criteria for
metaanalysis okay so the expert panel um
who's looking at all of these
21 uh has to reach consensus on the
topic area um and basically on not only
the quality but the effect size so if
the paper is discussing what happens to
eight people the effect size is pretty
low you'd like to be in the hundreds and
perhaps um even higher than that in the
thousands to know that um there were
enough people and enough tests that were
reviewed to actually make good
decisions um you have to evaluate the
individual practices overall strength um
of evidence and effect size consistency
so it's not only looking at the effect
size in one manuscript but in several
manuscripts that focus on the same um
body of
evidence um you need to develop final
draft practices evidence summaries and
draft recommendations and for the
quality ratings part of it they come up
to be either good fair or poor um and
for effect size ratings they're either
substantial moderate or minimal or none
because um they're talking about like
one or two patients um you provide
feedback to the um concerning the
limitations of the evidence review
process in the manuscript and possible
improvements for people who want to look
at the situation in their own
institutions and use these as quality
assurance guidelines and again for
people who do that um the CDC loves for
them to upload their data as gray
literature so we could either confirm or
deny the reports that we have um written
the first
time okay so what are some of the
lessons learned so far um first of all
there is information commonly missing or
inadequate in laboratory medic medicine
papers um and let me just tell you a few
of those that make it um hard to
actually use all of the literature one
is um a sample description the study
population being analyzed um is
incomplete or the setting is um not is
not really distinctive um and you can
just generalize so uh maybe it's all
about children which adds a bias maybe
it's all about males with which adds a
bias sometimes they don't even say um if
you're looking at the papers um what the
study population is they just say we
studied people who came into the
emergency department and you really
can't say were those children were those
adults were those males were those
females and you know did they come in
with heart attacks did they come in with
infections that kind of thing so if
you're thinking of writing a paper for
this um these are the kind of things you
should include um for sample size um
which is the number of patients that you
studied or the number of tests or um the
total number of samples sometimes people
give ad inadequate decisions so we can't
do a what I call a robust analysis of
the
practice um data collection method could
be also inadequately described so um
some people will say this was done for
the for the first three months the year
um some people will say um we just did
this and there is no um seasonality or
um any indication of um when these
specimens were were collected um and
they could not be really stratified um
other than as random specimens that came
in one after the other the time period
um the project and the intervention
start and end dates are usually missing
in some of the earlier paper papers but
included in some of the later papers and
then sometimes the intervention is
inadequately described um to allow it to
be replicated so um if you're looking at
something and somebody tells you I think
that this is a lot better um technique
and you have not described the technique
um you can't even tell what the
intervention is um the outcome measure
could be inadequately identified and
remember everything is p pent centered
one of the nice things about doing these
things is that we look at the patient
first and foremost um to decide like
what best practice is um a lot of people
have not applied statistical methods and
you know like they appoint um each other
as we used to do with the cumitech um to
be experts and then um they have not
like applied statistical methods to see
if things hold up to um a really intense
analysis and then um sometimes the cause
and effect relationship of intervention
and results cannot be clearly proven so
um this is where Again The Meta analyst
comes in because um the one we work with
for example at the American Society for
microbiology is um someone who has he's
an epidemiologist he has a master's in
um statistics at a bachelor's degree in
microbiology and he understands U not
only the microbiology part of it but he
understands it from an epidemiologic and
populationbased um
method okay so here is the abstraction
form and you know like when we're
training people at ASM who want to do
new um outcome measures um by this
method we use the um information that
you see
um here um in this form and it makes it
it it looks I and I guess my mind must
be you know like fairly rigid in this
way because I like the fact that you
have to all look for the same
information and it has to be there in
order for something to be included so
the first thing is just generalized um
demographic
information um the final thing on that
column that first column is funding um
and none of these things um really make
a difference in actually um looking at
the whether the paper has fundamentally
good information it's just um you know
who supported it um if somebody
supported it who the authors were um and
where they were
from um in the second column actually um
these are the first um points that
somebody makes uh and these are given
three points and basically it looks at
is there study bias um and is there
potential
generalizability for not only this
particular um outcome study but for
other things that people are looking at
and so you look at um the design of the
study um the facility or setting um
Children's Hospital University
affiliated hospital um Outpatient Clinic
uh you look at the time period you look
at the population that was sampled um
what is the comparator um again we have
we know our comparators here Vena
puncture versus um IV cath um photomy
Team versus no photomy team and
prepackaged kit versus no prepackaged
kit um and then is there any study bias
so um you know study bias is probably
the most difficult thing to assess and
it really helps for the statistician to
come in and help you with this um and
and you know like look at it um on the
back end almost because um basically it
has to be something that um is not just
limited to um one patient population or
if it is um that's okay but then it has
to fit in with what happened in that
other age group group um in some other
institution and again you get three
points for that um the next thing that
is assessed is the actual practice um
and you do a description of that the
duration um that the study lasted the
training um what staff and other
resources you needed and the cost of
doing this um and these are ways um that
actually um especially cost that people
look at what does it take to do these
kind of outcome studies and is It
ultimately going to lower the cost of
Health Care and you get two points
maximum for the
practice um the next column is for
outcome measurements and um you do a
description and um
recording um method um for everything
and again these can be by chart review
um the description you know like is
basically
um what was targeted in a particular
study which of the three outcomes did
they look at um and you have a maximum
there of two points as well the final
column is the results um finding and you
look at what the type of finding was um
was this in the analytical phase was
this in the um pre-analytical phase with
it's in the postanalytical phase um and
what is I mean obviously most of ours
are in the pre-analytical phase in this
particular question so if we had
something that was in the um analytical
phase it really is not
applicable um and you look at is there
do the people like test for statistical
significance um and were there any
results or conclusion biases that kind
of thing you get three points so that at
the end you add up the points um from
the four columns and the um First Column
where it says quality rating is an
actual overall look at what happened and
um pretty pretty much um what I could
tell you is this is a lot of work um to
really read and
analyze um each paper is um probably an
hour to an hour and a half for each
paper and you do get faster over time
but you need to find the answers to all
these questions while you're reading the
paper and the first time you usually
read it for you know like just an
overall view of what you would be doing
and then you really start to dig on
subsequent um
occasions okay so what it boils down to
at the end of the day is actually a um
Forest plot and I don't know how many of
you listening to this have ever seen a
far plot but over at the right hand side
um is a forest
plot um and what the bi what what the
meta analysis involved is actually
seeing um whether your comparator is
actually better than your actual
practice so that you know that the
intervention is working so this one is
um is is it um important to actually
have a commercial prep kit and you know
like if you look at the bottom um where
it says the number one when you look at
Forest plots and this is the easiest way
I could describe it to you um you look
to see um is one is is actually uh
meaning that the different papers that
you see here if they're on the line or
close to the one which they are there is
no difference that could be notated and
there were two um that actually were
over um and you can see you know like
the boxes um over on the um like column
for two and eight um but those really
are the only two most of the others are
around the um one so the decision in
this paper was to say that there really
is no difference there's no need to buy
a commercial prep kit because there was
no um instance that could be seen at
least in the papers that were studied on
whether the actual kit was better or
worse and so if you you know the answer
for this would be if you feel like it's
better for your hospital to buy that kit
than buy it if you don't it it and you
you go with individual components that's
probably fine too it does not seem to
have an effect on blood culture
contamination and the papers that were
looked at are listed there the ratings
that they got are listed Ed there the
statistical analysis is listed there um
and then all the one all the
abstractions that you saw um on the
previous slide are presented for all
those papers so that you could actually
look at these papers do your own
evaluation and see everything that the
people who did the abstractions have
seen okay so if you look at um Vena
puncture versus catheter collection
there's a clear winner here here and you
can see that practically every um one of
these papers that's shown on the left um
is showing that Vena puncture which you
see on the bottom there is definitely
Superior to catheter collection and that
catheter collection results in a lot
more blood culture
contamination okay this is f photomy
team and um again these are the five
paper that were evaluated for that um
and basically um again you can see that
there's a clear um rep you know like
recommendation for using a photomy team
um versus using just house staff nursing
or people really who haven't been
specifically trained in blood culture
collection now um to sort of wrap this
up and put this in a more Global
Perspective um and that is um why is
this even an important topic uh for an
evidence-based medicine
guideline um and so if you look in 1999
in
1991 um in jamama the um you can see in
this article called contaminant blood
cultures and resource
utilization that if you have a
contaminated blood culture it results in
an inreased length of stay um and in
this paper they estimated
12.5 versus 8
Days um it also results in increased
charges um for Health Care um
13,000 um versus um
8,700 it results in an increased
Pharmacy charges um400 versus
798 um and increased Laboratory charges
for the unnecessary workup the
identification and the susceptibility of
organisms that turn out not to be a
contaminant and these are $2,000 versus
$1,400 finally um in looking at
strategies to improve cost effectiveness
of blood
cultures um one of the issues um is
false positive cultures are definitely
higher when blood is drawn from
indwelling catheters than when is when
it is obtained by peripheral Vena
puncture and so um you know like the the
people who are doing the draws um have
to deal with a number of things and you
know does that mean that you can never
draw from an indwelling catheter no um I
mean I'm sure that there are situations
where um a stick for a patient who um
has had chemotherapy long-term
chemotherapy is going to be much more
difficult um and this is a better thing
to do but by and large it's much better
to actually you know like use the um do
an actual peripheral Vena puncture than
do something
else um so in doing that so what what do
you look at then um methods to reduce
false
positives um you can increase the time
and antiseptic scrubbing um you can wait
for the antip that you dry completely
which by the way are part of the um
preparation of the skin for collecting
blood cultures
anyway um you can choose an antiseptic
that is more effective than others in
clinical trials we didn't even get into
that here um you could Li limit the
number of venopuncture attempts before
preparing a second site um I'm sure
we've all seen the people who have been
you know they go in they go in they go
in and you know like they just can't get
it before they go um to something else
and then um there are issues about
requiring all cultures to be drawn by
train FLOTUS which we saw was better
also here so um one of the things to
think about if you're you know in the
business of drawing blood cultures and
listening to this is um to figure out
like in your institution how can do
things with a dedicated photomy team
with peripheral draws um and if you're
buying kits that cost more than the
individual components is this necessary
or can you save money by um not actually
doing that and that will be things that
are looked at during the um a A5 and A6
parts of the
cycle okay so um you can ask questions
by um actually typing in questions for
me um I'd be happy to answer some of
those um and thank you very much for
your attention
today um also the slides are available
in PDS for PDF form um if you actually
click the content button on your screen
and then go to
files thank
you
this the first time you've heard about
evidence-based medicine reviews it is a
mind blower so I can see where you may
not be able to formulate questions to be
honest with you I had to hear it
probably five or six times before it
started to make sense to
me but I do admire uh what the CDC has
done um for its robustness and
transparency
okay so if there are no questions um I
thank you for your attention um and you
know thank you for joining this webinar
um thank you